change lives yeah Davina lives change
organizations guy she organization
is awesome I change the world
thank you all for including me I'm not
an MBA as I said I'm a wannabe NBA I
went to Stanford many moons ago and in
my day I graduated in 1967 there were
not that many women who went on to the
business school it was so rare it was
kind of like weird almost when a woman
went on to business school and to see so
many powerful amazing accomplished
completely enlightened women in this
room that are in business that are
entrepreneurs that are running companies
that are doing incredible work in the
world all over the world is just it's so
heartwarming for me it almost makes me
cry so I just got to say Bravo
congratulations hallelujah to all of you
give yourself a big hand so I went to a
different kind of graduate school after
I graduated from Stanford I got involved
in making the world work is kind of the
business I got into and my professors my
teachers rather than being financial
professors or economics professors were
the resource poor people on this planet
I got very very deeply engaged and
committed to ending world hunger kind of
a large to do and I got involved with
starting and building something called
The Hunger Project which started with
just two people and an idea in 1977 and
now is in 100 countries around the world
as three hundred and seventy-five
thousand full-time volunteers is
operating offices all over the place and
really working very very powerfully in
intervening and social structures and
systems that hold hunger and poverty in
place and one of the primary and leading
interventions for ending world hunger is
empowering women is ending the brutal
almost heartless and unbelievably almost
unconfronted subjugation of women that's
taking place
in places all over the world and I
imagine you're fairly familiar with it
but I'm intimately familiar with it I'm
up close and personal familiar with it
and when you work on hunger and poverty
you see atrocities you see oppression
you see subjugation you see suffering
that is almost beyond what you can
tolerate but if you go toward it
instead of resisted what you see is the
extraordinary human spirit of women the
unbelievable power that we have inside
ourselves when there's no support and
when one is being oppressed the only
place women and human beings can go is
to find strength and courage within
themselves so my teachers have been
people that I used to call poor I
actually used to call people poor women
poor I would refer to them as poor women
until I worked with them until I was
side by side in the dirt after the
Ethiopian famine in 1984 1985 helping
women replant crops that had failed that
had been destroyed until I was
side-by-side with women and men but
mostly women in Bangladesh after a
horrendous flood where they had to
rebuild their homes until I knew women
who had been through such horrendous
rape and violence and sexual conflict
they couldn't believe that they were
upright and then I realized to call them
poor is so inappropriate and so not true
that who they are is whole and complete
people incredible people who exert
exhibit more courage to live through a
day than any of us in this room are
going to need in our entire lifetime and
to call them poor is to demean who they
are and sort of demean us who would look
at them that way when in fact they're
intelligent they may not know how to
read they haven't been given that
opportunity no education they're
incredibly creative
if you have ten kids and no food and
nothing inside and no water in sight you
have to be incredibly creative to make
it through a day and they're innovative
and they network and they support each
other and they draw on something that's
deeper than any financial pocketbook is
ever going to be or any economy is ever
going to give anyone they draw on a
spiritual power a deep profound
understanding of their own humanity in a
way that gets them through that day and
the next day and the next day and what I
began to see when I really saw that
these were my professors these were my
teachers these were my mentors these
were my coaches these were my godmothers
these were the people that I was going
to learn from from the rest of my life
that there was nothing poor about them
what's poor is the circumstances in
which they live and to label people by
their circumstances is to diminish them
and to diminish any of us so to call
them poor is something I never do now
and I talk about them the way they are
whole and complete heroic amazing people
living in resource-poor circumstances
and that's what's poor I also as you
probably would imagine if you're working
on ending world hunger you have to raise
a little money so I became the chief
fundraiser for The Hunger Project and
designed our fundraising strategies all
over the world and I trained 50,000
fundraisers I've raised hundreds of
millions of dollars and that's a real
teaching of its own and when you're a
fundraiser and I know many of you who
are you're looking for those people that
I used to call rich and you want to know
their phone number and you want to know
their email at that time there weren't
emails but you want to know everything
about them you want to know how to get
an introduction but as as someone who
now has raised hundreds of millions of
dollars and trained other people to do
so and not just people like you and me
but people in Mozambique to raise money
not from the World Bank but from
Mozambique
from each other taught people in Nigeria
or Ghana or Senegal or India or Sri
Lanka to raise money from each other
there wouldn't be large amounts but the
strength and power of asking people for
money in resource-poor circumstances
asking people who think they're poor
because they've been treated and
labelled that by the rest of the world
and have them actually make a financial
contribution to the betterment of their
own situation or the village in which
they live
liberate spiegel frees them has them
find something they didn't know was
there and so a lot of our fundraising
was with people you would never in a
million years ask for money except we
found that they have so much to give and
it's not in the big numbers but it's in
the incredible power of discovering that
they have something to contribute but as
I must say when you're running a budget
and I think you all know about that I
did need to go to people that I used to
call rich and I don't call them rich any
longer either even though you know it's
what everybody wants to be and perhaps
what all of us in this room are or
aspiring to be or maybe our two spades
in spades but when we label ourselves or
others by our circumstances it eclipses
the whole and complete beauty of who we
are and when you label people rich just
like when you label people poor what
happens is you start to think people
start to think they are their stock
options they are their net worth they
start thinking they are their trust fund
and that is not who we are we're people
living in resource-rich circumstances
and the ebb and flow of those resource
rich circumstances but we no matter what
happens with those circumstances want to
remember that we're whole and complete
people we are not our private plane or
our gated community so in in really
working all through the spectrum from
the ultra-wealthy
people on earth who on earth were
holding huge amounts of capital and
resources financial resources to people
living in absolute abject poverty and
many of them along that middle route
there and many of them women I've
learned a lot about money now not the
kind of thing that has me good at
reading a balance sheet the way you can
not the kind of thing that has me be a
savvy investor unfortunately but the
kind of thing that I've learned about
money is the dysfunctional really tragic
and anxious relationship that almost
everyone has with money no matter who
they are no matter where they are on
that big long spectrum even some of the
people right at the top of the charts
there are freaked out about money all
the time people have way more than they
can even spend not everybody but some
people in those ultra ultra stratosphere
of wealth are as anxious and upset and
have as much suffering amount money as
people who can barely pay their rent and
not everybody of course and I wouldn't
accuse any of you of this but there
might be a few people in here once in a
while have a little bit of anxiety about
money and don't like talking about it as
we said before so money has taken a
place a role in our culture and I'm not
talking about business now because as I
say I'm not a businesswoman I'm talking
really pretty much about life money and
you could even say the economy has taken
a role that's so exalted so lifted up so
worshipped that it has confused our
relationship with ourselves in my view
and we have to remember that we invented
money we invented it as a human species
about 4,500 years ago money historians
say they argue about when and where and
all that stuff but we invented it not
that long ago actually and we made it up
it's our invention money does not grow
on trees we probably have paid attention
to that notice that pennies do
not fall from heaven we invented money
and it's our creation and yet we've
become completely at the effect of that
which we invented and I would say
because and this is a little dicey to
say it Stanford Business School graduate
wind meeting but because we lie about it
the word lie is a kind of strong word
it's a little bit insulting and I'm not
insulting personally you or personally
me but the society in which we live the
global society particularly in the
United States but it's all over the
world is our relationship with money is
fraught with misunderstandings with
overblown importance with a kind of
worship that has us in a relationship
with money that's inauthentic and as a
society confusing for just about
everybody now that doesn't mean you
accept you live in a society that's
confused about money that's made it more
important actually than human life you
know money was invented to facilitate
the sharing of goods and resources with
one another for the well-being of all
except now it's not really used that way
all that much it's used to marginalize
to accumulate to to bring together in a
way that has power over and and so we
have made money more important than
human life in a society way that's what
I mean not you and I you and I know
money's not more important than your
relationship with your daughter or your
son or your husband or your partner or
your parents yet if people observe the
behavior of most of us they would say
gosh money is more important to that
person than anything and that's actually
the way our society foments and fosters
life so I suggest that some of these
lies which i think is an inauthentic
relationship with many are called a lie
to kind of insulted are born of
something that
I call a condition that we've invented
called scarcity and I consider that a
condition or a mythology that's gotten
all over everything in life now it makes
sense
to invent scarcity in a business I think
probably I think that's probably part of
what you do to make your product more
interesting than the next one and make
sure you get it before it runs out etc
but this condition of scarcity or what
I'll call it the lie of scarcity in a
culture that's consumed Erised and
monetized and commercialized in such
intensity that money has become the
be-all end-all instead of a tool that we
use for the well-being of life we have
become servants to money and so that is
not an authentic or powerful
relationship for human life or for the
well-being of the world and we all know
that and it creates this kind of
imperative for growth it creates a kind
of clamoring for more and this condition
of scarcity is almost like a helmet
we're wearing that we can't remember we
have on anymore I called it an
unconscious unexamined whole network of
assumptions where we actually without
thinking about it look at the world as
if number one there's not enough to go
around and someone somewhere is always
going to be left out as if we really
believe that's true but we haven't
really thought it through it's just an
unexamined unconscious assumption about
society about life about the world that
there's not enough that's toxic myth I
call it number one now I want to remind
you I've worked on hunger and poverty
I'm now working on the environment I'm
very very intimately familiar with the
fact that there are places where people
don't have enough food there's places
where people don't have enough water
I've held dying babies in my arms I
worked with women after the Ethiopian
famine who lost every single one of
their children to starvation one woman
had 11 children all of them starved to
death and some
how she was this big she was so slim and
slender and skinny she was still alive i
sat with her and six other women in a
circle for five days and five nights as
each one of the women in Ethiopia shared
about the excruciating death the
starvation death of each one of their
children until we had honored each one
of those little lives and they had
completed the story of the death of
those children I will never ever ever
get over that night that day that night
that day that night that day that night
that day they're here with me right now
as I stand before you and yet once they
had honored the life of each one of
those children that had died from
starvation if you can imagine it one of
the women shared about having the baby
her really almost newborn two month old
baby died suckling at her breast because
she hadn't had water herself in seven
days you imagine a baby dying on your
breast so this is like serious business
I'm talking about and these women were
in such incredible mourning and tragedy
and wailing that I didn't think they
were going to make it through this
session at the end of the five days and
five nights we rested we stopped wailing
we stopped crying and then they made a
commitment to each other and to me that
they would use the rest of their life as
women without children and their
husbands had long since abandoned them
to make a difference in Ethiopia that
would have no more women
no more mothers go through what they
went through and these are women were
totally uneducated and never been to
school you can't tell when people are
starving to death how old they are they
look very very old but I imagine they
were in their 30s maybe their early 40s
and I kept in touch with them over the
years and actually paired those seven
women up with seven when
in an investment club in New York women
in your position women who had
privileged women who had education women
who had money women who had
opportunities more opportunities than
they could handle
and they became like sisters those 14
women and the seven women in Ethiopia
we've lost track of three of them but
four of them went all the way through
school you know starting really with
kindergarten all the way through school
three of them have a PhD and one of them
is a lawyer and is running the largest
law firm in Ethiopia two of the PhDs are
in the Ethiopian government and the
other one runs a scientific institution
in Ethiopia and they didn't even start
going to school until the incident that
I'm telling you about
somehow I got off in the tributary I had
to tell you about them but what I want
to get back to is this myth of scarcity
the kind of runs are our mindset but
there's not enough to go around more is
always better and that's just the way
that it is there is not enough time
there's not enough money there's not
enough vacation there's not enough
weekends there's enough Tuesday there's
Tuesday's remember Thursdays there's not
enough hours in the day there's not
enough hours in the night there's not
enough this there's not enough that
there's not enough sex there's not a
love there's not enough definitely not
enough good men over 40 I know you've
noticed that that is true
but that there is not enough it's not
enough has become I'm not enough and we
become a deficit culture particularly
women not just it's not enough there's
not enough it's I'm not tall enough I'm
not thin enough I'm not blonde enough
I'm not young enough I'm not this enough
I'm not that enough and if you're in
advertising and marketing you're doing a
spectacular job of convincing us we need
more of just about everything
at every moment in time so the second
toxic myth in this scarcity model that I
think we're kind of caught in is more is
better
more of anything more of everything more
of whatever is better and it's kind of
an indiscriminate more and then the
third toxic myth first there's not
enough second more is better and third
that's just the way that it is and you
got to go with there is kind of a
blindness in the commercial culture we
live in that has us not recognized or
ever really have an experience of
fulfillment prosperity satisfaction
completion and in particular the
distinction of enough so let me go to
that because that's kind of what I want
to leave you with and I've discovered in
my work as a fundraiser as a
philanthropist and is working on hunger
and poverty and now working on
environmental issues with indigenous
peoples of the Amazon that what's
missing in our culture is a respect for
a reverence for an actual access to the
exquisite distinction of enough the
powerful experience of sufficiency and
I'll tell you I have a whole story about
how I got there and I don't have time to
tell it to you but I I really really got
this in an encounter with the great
Buckminster Fuller that we now live in a
world where we're doing so much more
with so much less really that we are
that we live in a world where there's
enough for everyone everywhere to have a
healthy and productive life as gone
he said there's enough for our need but
not for our greed and if you start to
actually think about that it begins to
change the very way you see the world
there's a principle that I call the
principle sufficiency now I made it up
so I don't know if you can make up a
principle maybe I discovered it but I
call it the principle of sufficiency and
it is this if you can let go of trying
to get more of what you don't really
need which is mostly what we're
clamoring to get more of it frees up
incredible locked up energy that was all
locked in that Chase to turn and pay
attention to what you already have when
you pay attention to what you already
have when you nourish it when you make a
difference with it when you give it your
attention and intention what's already
there it expands naturally so let me say
that again when you let go of clamoring
to get more of what you don't really
need gays being everywhere but where you
are it frees up oceans of energy to turn
and pay attention to what you have when
you pay attention to what you have
already when you make a difference with
it when you nourish it when you live in
the exquisite distinction of what's
already there it expands naturally I
call this the principle sufficiency and
a shorter way to say that whole thing is
what you appreciate appreciates what you
appreciate appreciates I say that you
can't get to true abundance true
abundance through the portal of more so
the portal of nor more it will always
lead you to lack and then you'll need
more again you'll get a high from that
but then we'll lead
lack and then you'll need more again I
say that the only route to true
abundance real abundance it isn't excess
but natural abundance is through the
exquisite portal doorway distinction of
enough of sufficiency when you're in
touch with sufficiency it overflows
naturally into abundance so I'm going to
give you one metaphor that I think will
help sort of keep this in existence for
you in a culture that clamors for more
that says there's not enough that's all
about scarcity and that is from my my
teacher and one of the people I greatly
revere I guess he's my mentor
I got a thing about that he's my mentor
he's my sponsor he's all that stuff his
name is brother David's tenderest he's a
Benedictine monk he's 85 years old he's
the greatest living scholar in the world
on gratefulness gratefulness he goes
into silence sometimes for a year or two
years at a time and when he comes out of
silence he has really great stuff to say
I can't tell you it's so great and I met
with a Mac Reed bin and Kamal the Lee's
down a Big Sur for two years in tall
silence he came to my house shortly
after that maybe it was a day or two
days I think he'd said something to
someone but and I had a session with him
and I asked him brother David given
you're the greatest leading scholar in
the world and recognized as the great
purveyor and an embodiment of
gratefulness what's the distinction
what's the difference between gratitude
and gratefulness and he said ah you know
he's really a cool guy you would love
him he said gratitude Lynn has two great
branches one is gratefulness the other
is Thanksgiving when you're in
gratefulness the bowl of life is so full
that it's almost overflowing but not
quite it's so full that it's bold at the
top but not yet dribbling over the edges
and when you're in that experience
you're in the great fullness of life
you're one with God if you think there
is one you're one with the universe
there is no other it's just all one and
that's so full filling so prosperous so
nurturing that the bowl of life
overflows and it's like a fountain and
that puts you over here in the other
branch of gratitude which is
Thanksgiving and the bowl of life is
constantly overflowing and when the bowl
of life is constantly overflowing you're
so grateful to discover oh there's an
other because all I want to do is give
and share and contribute and serve with
this incredible bounty and that is so
fulfilling it puts you in the great
bowls of life so if you get my metaphor
this is sufficiency this is the
recognition the distinction of enough
this is true abundance that flows only
really from enough and from living a
life where the overflowing power of
recognizing that you have enough you are
enough you live enough allows you to
have that more flow from the enough
rather than from the lack rather than
from the scarcity and when it flows from
there all you want to do is share it you
become a natural philanthropist you can
become a natural servant you share you
give you are you're just overwhelmed
with the beauty and meaning of being
someone who can make a difference with
your life so whether you are now a post
executive CEO you're now stay-at-home
mom or you are the CEO of a huge company
or you're an entrepreneur with a startup
or whether you're on the rise and a big
company no matter where you are you can
access the exquisite distinction of
enough and it doesn't mean you can't
have more it doesn't mean you can't be
on a track to improve and grow your
company your family your life
I suggest that you consider the
possibility that to be in the presence
of sufficiency to notice the bounty the
incredible blessing the absolute miracle
of your life will give you access to the
meaning that you may be chasing that's
already there because it will overflow
in a way that not only nurtures you but
nurtures the world and I will remind you
that those women in Ethiopia the people
that I've worked with all my life women
all over this world I now have the
profound privilege of being the
strategist and chief consultant to the
no-build of the nine living Nobel Peace
Prize women laureates and you know talk
about awesome women and what they've
been through
awesome Sanchi Rigoberta menchú tomb of
Guatemala Jody Williams of the United
States sure anybody who was head of the
Supreme Court in Iran under the Shah and
then was deposed by the by the Ayatollah
and now is her entire law firm has been
shut down she was she was defending
eighty percent of the women in prison in
Iran for in prison for not wearing a
veil for driving a car in prison for
life in some cases for not driver
driving car all of her lawyers have been
either jailed or killed
she's now not able to go back to her
country and she won the Nobel Prize and
she's as tough as awesome as committed
as she's ever been so that's just a
handful of some of the great women that
I've had the privilege of working with
including Mother Teresa at whose feet I
sat for many years so it's all business
the business of making a difference the
business of contribution the business of
finding your way to your own heart and
so I invite you I encourage you to
recognize the enoughness the bounty the
blessing in your own life and that
you're in the thousandth of the 1% of
the women in this world and to find your
way
to recognize the enoughness in a way
that it overflows into Thanksgiving and
you use your power your resources the
the now that is the only time we have
which is now and it's permanent and it's
always to make a difference particularly
for the women in this world who will
never ever have the chances you've had
so I'll stop there my time is up thank
you for listening and thank you for
being such spectacular women and for
standing up for yourself in a way that
you can stand for other women thank you
for being at a conference that allows
you to really delve into how to support
women changing their companies
themselves in the world and thank you
for inviting me to be part of it so now
I think it's question
I'm Carla and I wonder in your
experience what do you believe money is
the proxy for is the proxy for freedom
or safety or what is it that really is
pulling people toward money oh god what
a great question
shoot let me think do I have an answer
to that that's a great question
well I think we live in a culture that
has lost its way with money and it's
become an icon of power control and
domination and people want that now so
that they can avoid being controlled
being dominated or being powerless
because it's used unfortunately in many
cases not all obviously there's
wonderful things being done with money
by people in this room but you can feel
the prevailing the kind of winds are
that people with with access to money
often end up you know there's this sorry
if I can use your question to say a
little metaphor that I didn't get to I
learned from a woman in Harlem that I
was in a in a Harlem basement you know
doing a fundraiser with people in Harlem
and this woman stood up and this is in
my book the soul of money is one of my
favorite stories and I was asking for
money and and and most of the people
there were people from Harlan
african-american people they didn't have
a lot of extra resources and she stood
up and she said you know money is just
like water it's got to flow it's got to
move and when it moves it purifies it
cleanses it creates growth it can
nurture but when it's held and hoarded
just like water and over accumulated it
starts to get stagnant and a little
toxic to ever hope is holding on to it
they can't see any longer and I thought
that was a really incredible
for because if if we take only what we
need and not a lot more than hat because
we're not so cetera fide of being left
out which is kind of this scarcity model
then money can nourish and cleanse and
purify and and you know water the world
so it's I think it's comes from this
distorted understanding what money is
really for and it's a kind of energy
it's it's innocent yeah you know my book
is called the soul of money not because
I think money has a soul but I know that
we do and we can give soul to money and
we can bring money into things that our
soul longs to have happen in the world
and when money is an expression of our
highest commitments that's when we
actually feel prosperous not when we
have more money but when money we're
directing money in a way that fulfills
the highest commits we have for our our
loved ones our family and the world in
which we live that's the source of
prosperity so when it's like that then
money is doing what it's real job is I
believe that's the best answer I can
give you now but I'll think about that
thank you yes
so this might not be very articulate let
me give a shot so as I was listening to
your talk and I've heard a lot of those
themes before I was thinking about some
of the things we heard earlier and
things I heard in my business school
education about women of money so women
actually don't ask for money and don't
value money as much and a lot of the
messages I've heard is you know a young
professional woman was advocate for
yourself and go after money because the
men are doing it and so how do you sort
of I guess I'm hearing some conflicting
messages I'm trying to put it all
together does that make sense uh I hear
you okay um well no if it's a comment or
a question but it's something that I'm
stewing on okay good
I think women I think we're really
really good with money now
or similar prejudice because I am one
but I really think I mean if you think
about our Anatomy not to get too graphic
here we are set up to receive and out of
receiving we give birth men are designed
differently listening and I think much I
think women are the best fundraisers
from the heart I'll call it I think we
know how to receive we we sometimes
don't think we do but actually I think
if we pay attention to what actually
happens around women we are great
receivers were wonderful producers to
manner that you know kind of designed to
produce and we're kind of designed to
receive and that's anatomical you know
but at the same time we we all can do
everything but I really think we just
have a different relationship with money
and the conflict is we have a different
relationship with money than men do kind
of naturally and then if we try to
emulate men and learn from them that's
helpful because then we have a broader
spectrum of talent with money and if
more men would learn from us that would
be really really good you know there was
that article Time magazine had about
three weeks ago maybe a month ago they
had a covered women or the richer sex
did anybody see that it was wonderful I
have it with me and women are more and
more and more in charge of money in the
United States we have much much more
access now than we did when I was in
college it's just changing every minute
and you are a huge part of that and I
think that will change the dynamic of
humanity's relationship with money with
more women in charge of and in control
you could say or responsible for is I
think is a better term because I think
that's what we do we don't necessarily
control money we're responsible for it
which is a much healthier relationship I
think we'll see changes in the way
everybody relates to money and I hope
that's the way that it goes so I can't
resolve the conflict I can say the
distinction and the diversity and the
difference is something to respect not
try to reconcile but to expand and
include I'll say
back there with the you've been doing
this long enough to have seen business
cycles you've been in different parts of
the world were there different levels of
abundance and I'm struck by over the
last few years how much of a sense of
scarcity there is that's that's
portrayed through the media that's you
know there's this kind of constant
frantic tone about you know we're all on
the precipice we're all going over the
break and I'm curious about how over the
time you've been doing this work um
you've seen evolution in the way
people's attitudes towards money
responds to the larger circumstance of
are we in a time of abundance or a time
of scarcity in the economy
aha okay well we have one minute for
that huge question um but I'll say that
the you know it is not an answer okay
it's a response I don't have an answer
that question exactly because I haven't
I'm not a researcher I'm not McKinsey
where is Suzy it tells Suzy to work on
that I I'm not a researcher it's all
anecdotal it's all just wandering around
the world doing my thing but I will tell
you something that is probably not even
related to your question that I want to
say and your question is my excuse can I
do that I think the financial crisis
quote-unquote is one of the best things
that's ever happened to us now I know
it's painful I know personally I know
people have lost their homes I know
people who are destitute as a result I
worked with the madoff survivor group
150 families who lost everything and
they read my books all of money and I I
did conference calls with him once a
week so they could recover their sanity
because they were no suicidal these 150
families so I know the financial crisis
has been really painful so I don't don't
want to diminish that at all at the same
time I work in the environment now I
work with indigenous peoples of the
Amazon that's my most recent thing who
never even knew there was such a thing
called money you know they say you can't
hunt for it you can't eat it
why would you want it you know to them
it's like weird but but I this financial
downturn crisis meltdown that we've been
going through that's such a huge hot
topic and I know there's thousands and
thousands of reasons for it I think that
the source of it ultimately is that it's
time for a financial cleansing it's time
for a purification it's time for a
recalibration with our relationship with
money and growth and the economy we
cannot continue doing what we're doing
it everybody knows it now and a fact
that's important to tell you and you
probably know stuff like this please
forgive me I if I'm repeating something
you've studied but in 1987 was the year
when the human family went over a line a
very very dangerous and critical line
which is we now use more resources from
the earth then she can regenerate and it
was 1987 when we passed that line just
the human family not the other animals
even we use more resources from the
earth then she can regenerate 1987 was
when we went over the line so we're now
bankrupt in our relationship with the
ecology noticed eco eco pundits
historians people ecologists said it in
20 to 25 years will have a huge
financial crisis because the entire
economy is based on the ecology and the
ecology is now going into debt so we now
use as a today 2012 41 percent more
resources then the earth can regenerate
that's like living off an ecological
credit card you can never pay back we
can't pay it back so one theory one
thing I cert is that the financial
downturn is the early warning signs the
purification the recalibration the
purification you know the kind of
taking of us that we won't see the end
of until we begin to live within our
ecological means which will allow us to
once again find a way to live within our
economic means because the two are
totally related so I'm not an economist
I'm not an ecologist I'm I'm me but that
seems really clear to me so I offer that
as a way to look at your future the
future of business the future of
humanity and the future of women because
we know our intuition is way more active
and we pay much more attention to it
than the other sex and many people that
I work with call this the Sofia century
the century when women will take their
rightful role in co-equal partnership
with men and the indigenous people say
this is the century this is 100 years
when the Eagle of humanity which has
been flying with one wing over flying
and over muscled and the other wing
broken and a little bit weak so
humanity's been flying in circles this
is the century when the other wing the
wing of humanity which is female will be
strong enough to actually fly and the
other wing will stop being so nutty and
we will fly together in the same skies
and the world will come into balance and
that's a indigenous prophecy that makes
a lot of sense to me and you are the key
you are the answer you are the game
changers you're not just changing your
companies changing women and changing
the world you're the game changers for
Humanity so I bow to you I thank you and
hallelujah go forth and multiply
you
change wives Giada v9g lives change
organizations guy be instated
organization definitely also might
change the world